[Musique]
les calédoniens ont décidé par trois
fois de rester français cette victoire
elle est belle c'est la fin de l'accord
nommé à c'est le début de quelque chose
de nouveau dans la république française
la nouvelle calédonie restera donc
française que non à l'indépendance l'a
emporté à une écrasante majorité
96,49 % mais la participation s'est
avérée très faible c'est sans doute ici
dans l'état du kentucky
que les tornades ont frappé le plus fort
des lotissements anti ans comme disparus
des trains ont déraillé sous la force
des bras elles étaient 24 à semer la
terreur cette nuit quasiment simultanés
dans cinq états américains différents
bilan très provisoire pour l'instant au
moins 83 morts sur ces images aériennes
lusine de bougies de mayfield en miettes
cent dix personnes y travaillaient au
moment du passage de la tornade
épicentre de la catastrophe
cette ville de 10000 habitants est
quasiment rayées de la carte j'entends
les déceptions les peurs les divisions
qui sont pas des saisons moi c'est cette
fatigue que l'extrême droite ligne
droite des stands instrumentalisée à des
fins funès la division c'est la
résignation c'est l'impuissance c'est
l'abstention alors réveillez vous la
question du nom de la gauche vous en
pensez quoi et je n'en pense pas
beaucoup de bien parce que j'ai toujours
pas compris qu'il devait s'allier avec
qui à quatre mois du scrutin
comment ne pas entendre les françaises
et les français qui nous appellent à
l'union parce que c'est d'une hypocrisie
totale ces gens là ne cherche pas
l'union une sortie de secours ou le
savent aussi bien que moi sans férir
quelques-uns mais ils peuvent rire
qu'ils en profitent parce qu'on va
peut-être moins rire dans quelques
semaines avec ce qui va se passer dans
le cours de cette élection et la monter
l'extrême droite aux parents de toute la
petite équipe là chez de répandre du
désespoir de la résignation rien ne se
fera nous avons perdu d'adam équipe
c'est fou là c'est madame ida monsieur
montebourg quand je le vois à braver à
la fois les menaces et les quolibets ou
ed cet homme est courageux fait pas les
idées d'eric zemmour sur plein de sujets
mais un peu comme voltaire je n'ai pas
vos convictions mais je me battrai pour
que vous puissiez les exprimer
l'agressivité de certains journalistes
vont finir par rendre sympathique une
bonne nouvelle
la droite est de retour
après c'est peut-être une bonne
candidate pour versailles je crois pas
que ce soit une bonne candidate pour
parler aux électeurs de tourcoing je
regardais ce qu'elle avait fait quand
elle était pas ma place comme ministre
du budget elle a augmenté les impôts de
35 milliards d'euros elle a augmenté la
dette de 25 points et à la sortie il y
avait une croissance économique est à
zéro et un chômage à 10% les prix aux
prises en otage par les radicaux de sa
famille politique vous pensez à qui
monsieur ciotti par exemple monsieur
monsieur ciotti les pour l'agglo
guantanamo à la française bon je sais
dit visite vers plus radicale n'y a pas
de différence fondamentale selon vous
entre valérie pécresse emmanuel macron
pour des raisons il ya des différends je
veux je vais en giga nation un 1er mai
une anémie canal je veux un pointé une
économie elle le dit elle a dit très
clairement hier la droite est de retour
et ses actes réels de droite et macro
compatible
jusqu'ici
difficilement parce que ce café emmanuel
macron n'a rien à voir avec une
politique de droite si vous regardez les
prises de position des uns et des autres
dans les quatre dernières années ce que
disent d'ailleurs souvent les
adversaires de valérie pécresse sait que
de moins que l'on puisse dire est qu'il
ya eu des hésitations le moment où je
prendrai position y viendra mais il faut
faire en sorte que ce soit utile
et que ce soit un certain niveau
parce que la fonction qui a été la
mienne doit être respectée